we're getting a little breezy out there
we were pretty uh quiet overnight but
now things are starting to wind up a
little bit and we're looking at some
winds at the airport that have already
gusted to near 30 miles an hour we've
had 50 plus mile an hour winds up in the
mountains that's in the higher
elevations up there angel peak but 30
plus at kyle canyon red rock starting to
get breezy again mountain springs summit
between las vegas and
lots of 80s around the valley this
morning only a couple of spots in the
70s centennial hills mountains edge
seven hills where we hit 106 officially
yesterday it was a hot thursday we knew
it would be 80 degrees in boulder city
low 80s for mesquite boy indian springs
you are quite windy right now you've had
gusts over 30 miles an hour so the
temperatures have just jumped into the
low 80s with the help of the wind mid
70s for prompt and 84 in laughlin right
now with 60 up the road in caliani we're
looking for a high still in the triple
digits but not quite as hot as yesterday
102 and 100 is the average high sunset
tonight is 8 p.m
sunrise was 5 23. it's all because of
this area of low pressure that's pretty
strong plus a cold front so ahead of the
cold front comes the winds and we're
looking at southwest winds today 40 to
50 miles an hour all of southern nevada
southeast california northwest arizona
under wind advisories those start later
this morning they'll go all the way
until saturday night we're looking for
debris out on the roads blowing dust and
strong cross winds on the roads as well
so those wind advisories will be in
place for all of us if you're heading
out either to california arizona up to
utah you're going to get encounter some
strong cross winds as well as what we
said areas of dust blowing dust fire
weather warnings too
and that's because we're going to stay
super dry and then you add strong gusty
winds to that and just elevates the fire
weather danger 70s up there at mount
charleston today quite windy through the
mountains today please be careful if
you're headed out to the mountains and
103 at lake mead
windy as well and we expect boy those
white caps easily one to three feet of
white water out there on the lake today
with those 45 plus mile an hour winds
you've got to have the life jackets on
if you're headed out to the lake today
and into tomorrow the winds will stay
quite warm i know a lot of folks want to
celebrate dad this weekend wherever
you're going outdoors and especially
near water areas please just be extra
careful 102 for us uv index of 11 and
we're still looking at winds into
saturday but temperatures start to take
a little bit of a dip down to low 90s
even 90 degrees for sunday and
juneteenth on sunday but next week we
head into summer and boy those
temperatures head right back up to 105
plus